yeah disavowed Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian because of his position on
Trump Jamie's got a Google it is that
but but you know I don't bleed yeah
Jamie fastest one-handed tire in the
[ __ ] business look at that see it's
over [ __ ] twenty-two hours of guys
[ __ ]
the Daily Mail sever ties its in
hotnewhiphop calm it's on NME with NME
and new media entertainment sever ties
sever ties it's over we sever ties
[ __ ] we're not talking to you
anymore you don't come to our champagne
parties over [ __ ] watch the throne -
yeah but it's just more press an album
yeah clapping yeah well jay-z's probably
I can't do it that's crazy [ __ ]
anymore yeah but you know what this
whole thing with Kanye and this whole
push about getting Kaepernick to have
lunch with Trump it's brilliant
it's [ __ ] I think he used the whole
platform of SNL just to get Trump to go
I love Kanye he wants Trump to be so in
love with Kanye wants Trump to love him
so much that he's willing to actually
take a meeting with someone he's been
publicly [ __ ] on for a year now all
Trump has been doing is saying
Kaepernick is a terrible representation
of this country a bad football player a
bad person he's been dumped and dump a
dump and then Kanye he's gonna sucker
him and twist his mind into thinking he
should actually sit have lunch with him
I mean I bet my life it'll happen that
Trump will go okay I'll take a meeting
because I love Kanye and it's just out
of respect for Kanye so he'll get a
Samba he'll get him and [ __ ]
Kaepernick in the room I swear to God
watch it how I hope he does but here's
the thing Donald Trump's not a cop and
he's not shooting black people oh yeah
the whole thing is bizarre this way yeah
I don't know it makes no sense when
Kaepernick is on his knees during the
national anthem that's bizarre - yeah
because people are just there for a game
that's a game I completely understand
that you're disgusted by police
brutality sure I think virtually
everyone is yeah and my take on it is
its first of all it's insanely difficult
to be a police officer you have a lot of
people that are police officers that
have no
business holding that job there under
extreme pressure a lot of them have PTSD
and a lot of them they're bullies and
they get into this position because they
want to be the guy with the gun in
charge totally and then they have an
opportunity to pull that trigger and
they do and they face repercussions
because someone was filming it mm-hmm
and I think that [ __ ] has happened from
the beginning of time yeah of course and
there's film there's a horrible film
that we played where there was a guy I
posted it on my Twitter it's [ __ ]
horrible of a guy shooting a white guy
who's crawling for his life on the voice
telling the guy to crawl towards him let
me see your hands it's in Arizona and
the guy's pants have fallen down he
keeps reaching back to grab his pants
and he goes he goes I will [ __ ] shoot
you if you grab your pants and the guy
is crawling and his pants are falling
down tries to grab his pants and the guy
lights him up in the hallway of a hotel
yeah [ __ ] just kills him [ __ ] murdered
him the guy was crying and begging for
his life and the cop was making crawl
towards him like why the [ __ ] would you
ever make someone crawl towards you
that's insane
and he's giving them all these confusing
directions while he's in full riot gear
holding a gun apparently the guy had a
fake pistol like a water pistol or a
water gun and was holding it out the
window and someone saw it and they said
there's a guy with the guns and they
came in they're ready to shoot somebody
already and then they see this guy but
the guy was clearly not a threat you see
this and this guy had already been in
trouble for other police brutality and
then got kicked off the force he got
acquitted by the way.the with video got
acquitted and then he got acquitted of
the murder
yes acquitted he murdered this with the
video with the video got acquitted and
then afterwards got kicked off the force
for something else he did well the guy
was just an abusive guy at the time but
yeah he was just going off there's a lot
of people like that
totally and and there's also some that
are racist - it's not discounting racism
there's some that are racist - but it's
just a [ __ ] insanely difficult job
right no one respects or very few people
respect and these people are in these
situations every day where their life is
in danger yeah and their whole brain is
frazzled
I'm friends with a lot of cops I know a
lot of cops are had cops of my family I
know
a lot of cops from MMA I know a lot I've
known a lot of cops my whole life like
my whole life growing up my my real dad
was a cop I grew up like knowing cops
when I was a kid and then you know all
through martial arts knew cops because
cops are was taking martial arts to
learn how to defend themselves right
it's a [ __ ] insane job man yeah it's
crazy it's [ __ ] up and every day all
day long you're dealing with people that
are committing crimes you're dealing
with people that are lying you're
dealing with people that are lying to
you
right you pull people over their line
either they're drunk they're on drugs
they've got a body in the trunk it's
just lies well even a simple pullover is
alive when you know fast you're going
like knowledge it amelie had a broken
speedometer once and the cop pulled me
over and I go that's gonna sound so
[ __ ] stupid my speedometer doesn't
work he's like get that [ __ ] fixed I go
yeah I said let me go you know why I'm
white white dude white guy it was only
18 at the time black black dude is like
a name it's I mean you know it's not
even something to joke about
I'm sad that you just joked about it no
but it is [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up it is
[ __ ] up man but here's the thing right
ball players like capper to people like
that they kneel because they wanted what
they use in their platform yeah I mean I
get that you should use your [ __ ]
everyone should use their platform
here's my thing though has that helped
in any way well no see the problem is
there's no there's no okay the problem
is if you said to Kaepernick what's your
end game to say stop all police violence
is like such a vague broad thing does he
go yeah just stop it it's like well
that's not that this is to have a
dialogue about it was what's important
but the problem is they need to have we
need there needs to be a bigger goal for
why people are kneeling because the
conversation is already being had it's
not like we're kneeling so we can talk
about it what we're talking about it we
need that there needs to be some kind of
an end game a goal a point of that it's
not I'm not saying it's achievable it's
not necessarily going to happen but you
need you need something to - you need
something to get to because otherwise
this is just gonna be this weird turmoil
between ultimately racist people because
truly the people that are yelling about
it that are angry I don't give a [ __ ]
they take it knee are they still gonna
play football why do you care
but ultimately people that are like you
better stand up better stand up boys
it's for America
yeah ideas that we're all on the same
team I know but this if you don't want
to support the team but why why kneel
dirt but why then because it's because
people are paying attention that's
exactly right because they all the
eyeballs are on right but the idea about
a Nation about everybody being on the
team together we're supposed to support
right these ideals that this song is
about I pledge of allegiance to the flag
all this jazz I mean that's what we're
doing right I know but I find it so odd
that things have anything to do with one
another
I said it on stage one time that I was
like it's a game that has no bearing on
the future of the United States of
America you don't do that for anything
else right you don't just you don't have
like a dinner party and play Monopoly
and someone's like we should say the
Pledge of Allegiance it's one thing the
UFC stopped that I really liked was
saying I wouldn't do the [ __ ]
national anthem know what are we doing
we're here for cage fights two men
competing in a sport but it was a big
thing with boxing and it still is I
think he'll do the national anthems
before big boxing matches and it's
boring it's miserable so you see people
sing and it's when people do that thing
with their voice they try to be
Daytrotter they trying to make
that's a funny thing ever at any
sporting event in the middle of that
hole that blast stretch there's always
like 50,000 people go like these I think
the crossover is so [ __ ] silly we
don't need to be singing about America
at sporting events it doesn't have
anything that doesn't have a the
Olympics Olympics definitely that's what
it's [ __ ] about this is my country
versus your country but the duration is
about the Olympics I know but I'm just
saying I get that [ __ ] national
anthems at the Olympics that's what it
is but this is just the Packers versus
[ __ ] you know the Buccaneers this has
nothing you the bearing of American
future I go with the soldiers fought for
your right to be able to put so let's
fight for your right to be able to do
[ __ ] everything to do do we have to
now say it before this podcast right I
should okay we should has a goddamn flag
behind me know Santino goddamn American
flag but secretly the fans don't know
that Joe hates the Americans left on my
phone [ __ ] goddamn Americans see this
is this this is a [ __ ] this is
trolling he's trolling Joe is actually
Canadian nobody knows that shows a
conspiracy Rogan theorists online like
it's Joe actually born and I'm doing
Canadian propaganda on a sneak tip four
years